hello and welcome to this video playing
the hidden dragon
[Music]
not the dragon in this game
uh that's not really good but it's been
a while
i think bishop e3
knight c5 this h3
um h3 knight h6
e4 something like that i have a hard
time to remember
it's also b4
b4
is probably well e494
b4 is definitely a consideration
e4 is good for white as after knight 65
but it's before possible here if it is
it's certainly interesting or maybe
black goes some b6 know that also not
possible
come on let's play positional chess and
just say that this knight is awful
knight takes c5
maybe knight bt2
this is not like a complete refutation
of black's game
but it's pretty strong
what
no i don't think that this can work
first first you weaken yourself all over
the place and then you play f5 yeah
okay
yeah probably taking a knight c4 but
i wonder if there's something like
something crushing
don't see it at the moment
wow
so
yeah okay i just take that pawn black is
probably just playing uh
like whatever
what i usually call the drunken machine
gunner style just like
fire away and hope to hit something okay
one
probably d4 no he goes back okay
maybe he can go g5 actually it looks
pretty weird but
yeah knight g6 is kind of debatable if
this is good
either good or terrible one of the two
okay
trading off this active piece and
attacking e6
94 i can just take
i thought okay um
i s this at the end okay
let's play that
like in a very simple fashion just
net that pawn and try to play a
technical game
here with the time being
low or it's
the constant problem trying to refute
really bad positions and then
[Music]
i'm struggling with the time
i mean black's black's position looked
so bad that
it looked like some some killing
um some killing line
should be there but i didn't find it
yeah so here
how do we organize this actually
this one
unsure g4 is a move
no no i'm not quite sure
try to make his bishop look silly on g7
rook d7 probably
okay
[Music]
yeah rook d1 next
that was a really odd game
okay seven i guess so on yeah rook t7
still don't have much time but i mean i
have everything very nicely coordinated
that was a very strangely played game
so this is this is a known line yeah so
this this
goes back and queen d5 simply okay
i kind of remembered e4 but it's
probably i was just confusing this
queen d5 looks yeah
looks good cover this
attack this and just put the queen in
the middle of the board
yeah that was a lot better even
and this is indeed not totally clear at
all he can go
d5 wow that's awful i mean i saw the
move but
i thought that here queen takes
is killing for me or i'm killing him but
this is not true really because he has
knight a4 which i did not see
wow wow
now it badly played opening
i mean by both sides yeah he's allowing
me a large advantage and i don't
exploit it i was really confusing lines
here and there's something quite similar
in the book
f5 is really a somewhat crazy move
doesn't even seem to be so terrible i
mean d5 was better but
it's not even a large advantage that's
crazy
yeah he's got just two center pawns yeah
i mean his king position is a wreck
but the two center pawns seem to be
really doing a good job here
rookie one knight f7
knight h4 yeah this was probably not
good because of g5 which he didn't play
yeah because i just have to go back yeah
this this cannot be right
i have no squares for that piece if he
goes here for example
it is uh it is getting trapped
so after g5 i would have gone back so
knight h4 was a lemon and
yeah this is weird
but it seems to be okay for black king
h7
is a bit strange so i was happy to trade
this
and then he played knight e4 which felt
unplayable
okay i have ah okay i have a nice strike
here knight g6
because probably rp4 works yeah okay i
didn't see that
this is nice and this is
winning the house i guess yeah that is
winning the house
and king h6 queen h5 is killing the king
is just so bad
nice that's nice nope
beyond my capacity but i
you know i didn't have so much time and
i was happy about
to just take this and have a pawn up
yeah and play a technical game where in
30 seconds i can make reasonable moves
probably not the best moves but moves
that somehow
were yeah coordinating things
rook c8 for compensation one one problem
with my position is that those two
pieces are
not ideally coordinated and i
i i managed this a little bit like with
knight d4 knight e4
knight f3 king g6 it's still tough
knight h2 for g4
he went back and now g4 trying to make
his
um bishop on g7 look silly
yeah and this is actually what i
expected that he would take
and play knight d6 and i wasn't so sure
about all this
i would have not played rook before
something probably just go back
and black has yeah it's still kind of
active here
bishop c8 is allowing me to completely
coordinate and now
this looks pretty pretty nice
i still would have thought he placed the
rook back and then this
i mean by now my my pieces have
dramatically improved but
you still have to win this king f2 maybe
yeah it's pretty nice but uh he gave me
more material even
okay guys thanks for watching